bienvenidos a la presentación dividiendo
decimales bueno vamos a atacar el
problema ya de una vez
ok queremos dividir 23.8 28 entre punto
28 y bueno como dividimos algo si aquí
tiene punto decimal por acá osea cuántas
veces cabe punto 28 en 23 está
complicado pensarlo de esa forma no
entonces mejor lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar tanto la parte de adentro
como la de afuera por cien y entonces el
punto decimal se va a recorrer dos
números hacia la derecha igual por aquí
dos números hacia la derecha y entonces
ahora va a ser mucho más fácil pensar en
cuántas veces cabe 28 en 2.382 punto 8
otra forma es verlo con las fracciones
aquí lo que tenemos es 23.8 28 entre
punto 28 y lo que hacemos es multiplicar
tanto arriba como abajo por 100
y entonces cómo estaban multiplicando
arriba y abajo entonces realmente no
estamos afectando a esta división a esta
fracción y bueno eso es tal cual
exactamente igual a 23 82.8 entre 28 que
es justo lo que nos queda aquí pero
bueno hay que volver a dejar el espacio
para hacer la división porque si no nos
vamos a hacer muchas bolas ok entonces
cuántas veces cada 28 en 23 pues ninguna
non entonces tenemos que irnos hasta
este lugar y ahora sí cuántas veces cabe
28 en 238 pues 238 se parece mucho a 240
no y 28 se parece mucho a 30
entonces 240 entre 30 o sea esta
división no se reduce a ésta pero sí nos
puede aproximar podemos dividir entre 10
adentro y afuera y 24 entre 3 cuánto es
pues 3 por 8 es 24 no
entonces yo digo que pone aquí un 8 es
un muy buen intento o sea todavía nos
falta ver pero o sea 8 suena que va a
estar muy bien borremos este pedazo y
ahora sí 8 por 8 64 entonces ponemos el
4 por aquí y el 6 por aquí para que no
se nos olvide sumarlo y entonces 8 por 2
16 más 6 22 22 y tenemos que restar esto
menos esto entonces 8 menos 443 menos 2
1 y 2 menos 20 entonces lo dejamos así y
bajamos el 2
y otra vez 142 se parece mucho a 140 y
28 se parece mucho a 30
y entonces pues vamos a quitarle los
ceros dividir entre 10 adentro y afuera
y bueno 14 entre 3 pues 3 por 4 son 12 y
está muy cerca del 14 ok entonces aquí
me voy a aventurar a decir que por aquí
tal vez vaya a un 4 y vamos a borrar
esto y ahora vamos a ver si sigue en
serio va aquí un 4 o no entonces 4 x 8
32 ponemos aquí el 2 y por aquí vamos a
poner el 3 para que no se nos olvide
sumarlo 4 por 2 8 3 11 entonces vamos a
ponerlo por aquí
y hacemos la resta 2 menos 204 menos 131
menos 10 por lo menos ya vimos que el 28
si cada 4 veces dentro del 142 pero
ustedes que dicen el 4 si va aquí o no
va aquí pues resulta que este residuo es
más grande que este número y eso lo que
significa es que pudimos haber puesto
aquí un número más grande todavía y
tenemos que ponerlo o sea tenemos que
poner aquí el número más grande que
quepa aquí ok entonces el 4 no va aquí
sin embargo pues esto nos sirve para
saber qué número si va aquí o sea el 28
cabe otra vez dentro del 30 y entonces
aquí nada más tenemos que sumarle un 1
entonces pues ya sabemos que aquí va el
5 pero tenemos que borrar todo esto
entonces activa el 5
5 x 8 40
entonces llevamos 45 por 2 10 4 14
y restamos eso y nos queda aquí nada más
el 2 entonces bajamos el 8
y cuántas veces cabe el 28 dentro del 28
pues caben exactamente una decena o sea
1 por 28 28 restamos y nos queda 0 y
mirad nada más
o sea ni siquiera vamos a tener que
redondear a las milésimas porque aquí
estoy ya fue una división exacta o sea
2300 82.8 es exactamente igual a 28 x
85.1 así que nunca se les olvide poner
el punto decimal entonces como el
residuo es 0 ya se acabó la división y
es una división exacta y no tuvimos que
redondear entonces 2.380 y 2.8 entre 28
es igual a 85.1 y eso lo que significa
cómo podemos dividir entre 128 como a
2.380 y 2.8 eso lo que significa es que
23.8 28 entre punto 28 también es
exactamente igual a 80 y 5.1
y eso si tiene sentido o no a diferencia
de si se me hubiera olvidado poner el
punto decimal light osea 23.8 28 en 3.28
definitivamente no va a ser del estilo
851 no eso es algo que siempre hay que
checar cuando estemos haciendo
divisiones que más o menos tenga sentido
lo que acabamos de obtener bueno yo creo
que sería bueno hacer otro ejercicio
entonces vamos a empezar por borrarlo
todo
ahora vamos a dividir 43.23
/ 3.3 muy bien entonces hacemos lo mismo
multiplicamos adentro y afuera por 10 y
entonces el decimal pasa para quedar y
éste pasa para que y recordemos que
siempre que multipliquemos adentro y
afuera por exactamente la misma cantidad
no hay ningún problema entonces cuántas
veces cabe el 33 en el 4 pues 0 no
y cuántas veces cabe el 33 en un 43 pues
caben una vez entonces uno por 33 33
43 33 pues eso simplemente son 10 no
y ahora si bajamos el 2 y tenemos 102 y
aquí pues con un ojo de buen cubero yo
digo que son 3 porque porque 3 por 33
son 99 y eso está muy cercano a 102 y
ese es el chiste probar con algunos
números que creamos que va a funcionar
checar si si funciona o no funciona y
arreglarlo si no funciona pero bueno
aquí si va a funcionar 3 por 33 son 99
102 menos 99 son 3 bajamos el otro 3
y ahora sí cuántas veces cabe 33 en 33
pues una sola vez y tenemos 0 de
residuos ok
1 por 33 son 33 los restamos y ahora sí
nos queda 0 de residuo entonces 432
punto 3 entre 33 es exactamente 13.1 no
tuvimos que redondear nada y como
podemos mover el punto decimal todas las
cifras que queramos hacia la izquierda
hacia la derecha siempre y cuando el
punto decimal de adentro lo movamos la
misma cantidad de cifras
entonces 43.23 entre 3.3 también es 13.1
bueno ahora vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
ahora vamos a dividir puntos 3 3 5
entre 2.5 que ya hacemos exactamente lo
mismo
multiplicamos adentro y afuera por 10 o
sea movemos el punto decimal un lugar a
la derecha de afuera y por lo tanto
tenemos que mover este punto decimal un
lugar a la derecha entonces queda por
acá y ahora sí cuántas veces cabe 25 en
3 pues nada más para divertirnos vamos a
poner el 0 por aquí y cuántas veces cabe
el 25 en el 33 pues cabe 11 por 25 25
restamos 33 menos 25 son 8 bajamos el 5
y bueno aquí yo le calculo así nada más
echándole un vistazo que cabe como 3
veces 3 por 25 son 75 y entonces 85
menos 75 son 10
aquí nos queda un residuo distinto de 0
pero siempre a la derecha del punto
decimal podemos agregar ceros
entonces vamos a bajar un cero
entonces aquí hay otro 0 y 25 cada 4
veces en el 104 por 5 son 20 24 por 4
son 8 más 210 o sea 4 por 25 si son 100
restamos y nos queda residuo cero y
entonces 3.35 entre 25 es exactamente
igual a punto 134 o lo que es
exactamente lo mismo punto 335 entre 2.5
es exactamente igual a punto 134 el
chiste aquí es recorrer el punto decimal
aunque hay una vez que los recorres esta
división se convierte en una división de
nivel 4 como las que seguramente ya has
hecho y una vez que se convierte en una
división de ese estilo pues esto muchas
veces se trata de probar con un número
ver si funciona y si no funciona aprobar
con otro número hasta que ya encuentres
la respuesta correcta y si te equivocas
no te sientas mal vuelves a empezar nada
más
va a quedar muy bien al final lo que sí
hay que recordar muy bien es que para
mover el punto decimal del lugar tienes
que moverlo hacia la derecha exactamente
la misma cantidad de veces afuera que
adentro ok y que esto lo que significa
es que estás multiplicando por 10
adentro y afuera al mismo tiempo y como
las divisiones son como las fracciones
entonces realmente es la misma división
el resultado es el mismo
ok cuando tengas números decimales por
acá cuentas la cantidad de pasos que
tienes que mover el punto decimal a la
derecha y mueves este decimal esa misma
cantidad de lugares y el resultado que
nos dé aquí es exactamente el mismo
cuando el punto decimal está aquí que
cuando el punto decimal está acá bueno
yo creo que ya estás muy listo para
hacer ejercicios de divisiones con
decimales por acá